this morning Tick Tock CEO will make his
first ever appearance on Capitol Hill
today's house hearing on Online safety
comes as the video sharing app faces
intense scrutiny with some lawmakers
proposing a complete ban a new CBS News
poll shows 61 percent of those surveyed
favor a ban but that number is smallest
among young people were more likely to
use tick tock still 56 percent consider
the platform a potential National
Security risk Nicole Killian joins us
from the hearing room Nicole good
morning
hey good morning to you Vlad Tick Tock
CEO insist his platform is safe and
warns any attempts to ban it could hurt
businesses and the U.S economy
hi everyone it's Joe here today the
chief executive of tick tock holds out
the platform's 150 million users that's
almost half of the US coming to tick
tock and address lawmaker concerns about
National Security shozi Chu tells the
house Energy and Commerce Committee its
parent company by Dent which is based in
Beijing is not owned or controlled by
the Chinese government and he outlines a
plan to set up a new firewall to seal
off protected U.S user data from
unauthorized foreign access we don't
want this data in the hands of the
Chinese Communist party period Chu's
testimony comes amid bipartisan calls to
restrict the video sharing platform or
ban it all together you're not ready to
go as far as a band we need to have all
options on the table why this is so
important to me is because I've got
nieces I've got nephews I I know
incredible content creators that are out
there we as a country need to make sure
that we are all safe in December by
dance admitted that employees access the
data of American Tick Tock users
including journalists and some of their
contacts President Biden signed a law
Banning the app on government devices
over spying concerns and has called on
by dance to divest from Tick Tock to
avoid a U.S ban but the company says it
doesn't solve the problem it comes down
to
um you know who really controls this
company we were brought out by Tick Tock
to come to DC our stories ahead of the
hearing tiktok has stepped up its
lobbying efforts and paid for a group of
creators to come advocate in Washington
if the app were shut down it would be
detrimental of course for me and my
business
Tick Tock is one of the most downloaded
apps outpacing Rivals like Instagram
Snapchat and Facebook and it's used by a
lot of young people so in today's
hearing she will likely face a lot of
pressing questions from lawmakers about
what Tick Tock is doing to keep Kids
Safe Tony
this was also an interest of the Trump
Administration as well so now this is
the second presidential Administration
to look at Tick Tock very hard Nicole
thank you very much